[Music]
Kylie Jenner's Halloween and we're just
living in it the beauty mogul stepped
out in another iconic look on Wednesday
night as The Little Mermaid to party
with her bestie Stassi rocking Ariel's
long a red locks a sequined tail skirt
and of course that iconic and revealing
shell bra which put her voluptuous
figure on full display it's worth noting
this is a bit of a repeat costume in the
kardashian-jenner family look in 2012
it's been a full week of Kylie ween as
the 22-year old reality star kicked off
the spooky holiday with a transformation
into Madonna at the 2003 MTV Video Music
Awards where the legend shared that
iconic kiss with Britney Spears Kylie
matched Madonna's blonde locks and sexy
black ensemble to a tee and recruited
her bestie Stassi to dress up as Brit
and yes they recreated the smooch then
there was the Playboy Bunnies Kylie
proudly wore the black satin corset
complete with ears black tights white
cuffs and a bowtie all over social media
the look comes just months after the
Kylie cosmetics founder posed for the
mag with ven boyfriend Travis Scott
[Music]